by the end of the week the age group
from 12
to 15 could be eligible to get the
pfizer vaccine while the fda has
approved it
the southern nevada health district is
awaiting recommendations from the cdc
those recommendations expected tomorrow
this news has many parents talking sally
jeremiah spoke to some of them today
brian over the past few months i've done
several reports here at the las vegas
convention center tonight
we've been vaccinating people down to
age 16 for
the entire year now and i feel that
things should be pretty much the same
for
children age 12 to 15 now pediatrician
dr
michael tenby understands children
aren't at the same risk of serious
complications like adults
but they can get sick and spread the
virus this age group is very exciting
you know that they're
out there they're mixing with their
friends they're more exposed we're now
in classrooms
so i think it's great dr tambie says he
is getting a lot of questions from both
parents and children
even his own son a lot too my my son in
particular is very excited about getting
that vaccine
we're excited to get it for him and then
he'll be excited to go back and
go back to school for other parents they
are worried about the long-term effects
my thoughts are just the fact that we
haven't seen
a big increase or influx of these kids
getting sick
with the chronovirus to inject something
that is not
quite well known yet walter fredenberg
has three kids
ages 11 14 and 18 and not one of his
children has asked to get the vaccine
and have resumed sports and seeing
friends
i think that for these children that
want to get back to normal life and
everything else i think that's what we
just have to let them do is just
act a normal life with or without a
vaccine felicia littell wants more
research done
especially for her daughter who has
asthma they're required for school
unfortunately i'm going to have to get
it because my kid needs to be around
other kids
i believe this vaccine will be very well
tolerated along with
you know normal routine medicines
allergy medicines adhd medicines
things like that